listen you gotta focus you're smart
academically
you've been lazy if you're lazy man you
mind will be stupid that's all we ever
hear is sky's the limit
please we are no record companies it
done but everybody's still trying to
blow up like Drake and Kanye and most of
these athletes won't even come close to
going press but they all still trying to
ball the truth is you can't get
everything you want out of life unless
you got a real legit plan all of them
and email blasts so your business man
huh come on lil mama look at his face
drop it drop it rain suit so kneecaps
and leave you walk away
damn can't even get my money together
I'm shutting you down what's going on I
don't know man the cops are here over
there going in get that money and ain't
nobody gonna get out
then I pass fail right way to go to jail
Oh priceless s who define success y'all
will win play ball the rap but when that
don't happen
it ain't no going back we dropped out
too young now you just watch the cap
scarlet blu-ray it's really black black
being sure be educated ain't a part of a
plan we got trip to get sleep again fell
back in that pigskin again